is there some aspect of celebrity that's
isolating that can make you feel really
lonely not me I don't feel no not really
you feel the love no I just feel like
I'm not I mean it's like
I don't know I've always kind of had a
small group of friends and those people
don't you know it's like I've known the
same people for years and years you
never really felt the celebrity really
nah in L.A it's hard to it's hard for
people nobody cares they see you and
then the next minute they see so and so
so it's like you know I'm the guy from
that hey that uh Mike and Molly right
nope yeah nope close king of uh King you
just shave your head you go ball are you
king Queens nope it's not me so close
you're wow [ __ ] look uh you were used to
be the mountain on uh Game of Thrones
you look like [ __ ] what happened
just eating fried dough yeah um yeah
that's what's up can't lift any weights
anymore I'm at the gym doing like 15
pounds with shoulder press ah and people
coming up to me
you used to be a dragon killer if a man
used to be yeah what's have there been
low points in your life
sorry to go there but
uh yeah yeah yeah
hey yeah
yeah there's everybody has a low point
in life The Operators suffer from like
depression any of those kinds of things
you know what I do I do I have uh I have
a bunch of stuff
how do you deal with it said friends the
friends and the they don't do anything
for me yeah I have a I have an
incredible fiance who uh that that's
nice to have somebody uh uh constant
that you love very much and see is the
best person and all that good stuff
hopefully vice versa uh and then well on
your recent Instagram she said
that she loves you so wow yeah allegedly
that might all be for yeah that's how
much money did you pay her to say that I
don't I don't have any because I'm not a
stand-up I was like I could do you got
venmo yeah yeah I got I only have like
123 I use some Dogecoin yes some Doge
yeah you want some Doge I got some of
those monkey nfts oh before I forget yes
hold on a second
oh no
I put a doozy sticker on your microphone
if that's okay sure
here oh yeah now these are tricky
because I have the thumbs of a I have
like Italian sausages
I'm just gonna this will take another
yeah yeah
oh man yeah ooh this is embarrassing
when there's are you good under pressure
I have anxiety I have performance
anxiety do you have anxiety yeah you
have anxiety period period yeah I I like
I don't like it when I if I have to pee
and then everyone's waiting
and you're not yeah yeah I don't like it
you know what will help you in that
situation what's that taking a [ __ ]
because whenever you take a [ __ ] you
always pee a little it's hard to take a
[ __ ] while you're standing at a urinal
but not in my world okay you just got to
keep yourself full of things that make
you [ __ ] oh good you ever heard of a
banana
I did recently somebody told me about it
not the Showbiz term I'm talking about
the food there you go
there we go
which way is up it's this way it's like
a d no it's been it there you go all
right
thank you
ah so sexy
you're like a brand yeah it's very
important to Brand yourself these colors
are you selling shoes
yeah I got some uh custom kicks coming
out the dudes he uh no actually that
would be a good idea
you can probably sell a pair of two of
those speaking of anxiety I really am
only focused on this right now Alex I
apologize just [ __ ] your pants it'll
make you be easier get on with it oh
this thing has been dog-eared in my
pocket for a while I swear this never
happens to me I'm sorry babe people
don't thumb it a sticker for an hour
while they're doing the product this is
just an excuse you make when you're with
somebody and you're underperforming well
here's the thing as you ask me questions
that I don't want to answer I'll just go
to this don't go to the sticker so if
this doesn't mean let me just ends up
working then I won't have it finally you
started doing that when we're talking
about depression that's weird that is
weird
tell me tell me how that makes you feel
um
here we are we got it for the listener
he succeeded after 10 minutes yeah you
know no I do have I do have uh some of
that stuff Bobby Lee
uh has had encouraged me on on wax as I
like to say to go to talk about it on
podcasts talk about depression because
it could help people and I said no but
um
it's true I do I do have some there's uh
there's some history in the family how
do you overcome it well I used to not
believe in medication at all I used to
think that that was for someone else
with uh who's been diagnosed with uh
some of the
some of the rougher stuff but as I got
older then some of the stuff happens and
you know you have to
and by stuff I mean uh you know mental
stuff and uh and yeah so I went and I I
just I believe that the stigma needs to
be removed completely 100 uh and so I've
I you know I do therapy I do talk
therapy I I'm on a little bit of stuff
which which let me tell you when I first
started it
I was um you know someone I'm close to
was like my manager and she goes this is
too much but she was like yeah you don't
have to White Knuckle it through life
right because I was literally just like
everything became
you know really hard to do at a level
that I wanted to do it at even just
getting through your day right uh and
when I first
um got some of the
the meds that I was on that I'm on it
felt like doors and windows were opening
literally in my brain I took a a three
hour nap the first day
and you shouldn't even feel this stuff
the first day I think my brain was like
it was like a sponge it wanted to I
needed some relief and I'm not a nap guy
I can sleep three hours and I'll be fine
um but I I took a long nap and then I it
started to it started to help yeah it's
not weird how a little bit of chemistry
in your head
can the kids just make the whole world
appear it's so much more beautiful yeah
yeah yeah I mean after after all there
you know there's a lot going on in your
brain that can be changed by you know
your lifestyle but also so many physical
things like a little bit of meds or in
Bobby's case uh you know thumbing around
on some dumb farming app